now stop getting that kidnapping
children
of the Muslims brainwashing them and
giving them to people that they have
nothing to do with them we know you the
children are clearly coming out saying
who are happy with our parents Sweden is
on a mission to destroy families
for Allah always watching the commentary
in Sweden that's to get gay yeah
Shout
and one of the gay his grandmother or
his mother she was with him
and he said they asked the gate said
would you choose the clothes for your
son or you leave him to choose if he's a
male or female he said no to believe him
that the mother exposed him says no
truth he said how many times the son I
see him trying to pick up the boys
clothes and my son goes and take him
away
so it's okay to brainwash our children
but if you want to do it yes
that's why you know one thing I have to
say about Britain I must be many times
one of the best countries in the Western
World for the Muslims in Britain Britain
well now we have to be just saying it's
perfect but you have to be just you know
we'll lie like you